Petra,
there's a really frightening man behind you.
He looks really serious.
Yeah.
That would really freak her out.
I can't say things like that in our relationship.
You want this one?
No.
Should I be nervous?
You know,
I have no filter.
She has no filter.
My name is Robin.
I'm Petra.
Eight months.
Well we were on the base at the same time,
so we kind of remembered.
Yeah,
it was June of last year and we met an ecstatic dance and I just remember him
kind of like coming up next to me would be,
sorry,
Gen z,
can you folks?
Smiley lead.
And he's really cute.
And I was just like,
wow.
He shiny
good music.
Good choice.
Yeah,
totally.
I have no idea what you were saying was enjoying.
You're smiling and laughing.
I hope that was like a thing.
Um,
we were at an event called ecstatic dance.
I was just dancing and doing my thing.
And then behind me I see this like bright shiny girl,
just like skipping around the room.
I was like,
oh,
hey.
Um,
after the event we started to chat a little bit and I could just tell that we,
that we were just engaged,
that we would just really present with each other
first impression.
It's like literally,
wouldn't you like movies?
A handler?
Like seek glitter,
go ahead.
It was actually really awkward.
Like,
and we've never talked about this.
I like totally not ready for it.
Totally caught me off guard.
And you know how in like hitch,
I think they say you've got to be like 50,
50,
or 80,
20 or so,
people like that.
And he was like full on like what Chris said,
I was just like,
whoa.
Like,
okay.
And it was just like,
all right,
I guess he's into me.
I just felt like I was,
we were in the friend zone and like,
or in danger of it.
So I like,
I just at the end,
it's a bit embarrassing now,
but I just like leaned in and kissed her and it was pretty awkward and a bit
sort of like Steph,
but like I just,
I don't know,
I just kind of had to let her know like,
look,
I don't want to be in the friend zone.
And I guess that was my way of expressing that.
Oh yeah.
We haven't really spoken about that
now said at the time that it has to come up.
Right.
Well first of all,
I'm sorry,
I'm sorry that I was comes in that moment and maybe couldn't articulate through
words that,
hey,
I think you're nice and I'm going to be really cool,
but hey,
I just at least wanting to express to you that I like it.
Okay.
I forgot to talk about that first kiss.
It's done
on camera.
Great.
I just remembered like being in bed with him and I was just like,
Robin.
I said,
can I tell you something?
You're going to be cured.
He knew what I was going to say and he was just like,
do you love me?
We'd been dating for like a month or so.
I think one morning she sort of looked over at me and was like,
I um,
I kind of,
um,
and she,
she didn't quite go through with saying the words,
but I kind of looked over at her and was like,
yeah,
and I'm trying to think,
did she actually say it?
I think one of like the best day ever we call it was December 14th of last year
and we went down to San Diego to get his passport for the Swedish.
Yeah,
we just need like a whole day out of it.
We go to Balboa Park and like we're both imagining like,
oh,
it's an enormous park.
We're going to pick nick,
am I going to play?
And it's gonna be amazing.
We get there.
It's like so much traffic and there's like not much park.
We were just looking for nature and so we just got lost in a parking lot
forever.
He lived since like,
we let us grab with the parent at the parks here suck.
And it was Christmas,
so all the lights were up and the fountain was doing like beautiful things and
so she brought these penguin Christmas hats.
So we were both like going around just like a silly penguins and we just had the
most incredible day from morning tonight and it will forever be known as the
best thing ever and we will celebrate that day with Penguin Christmas hat.
That's when you really tap into your inner being when
I'm going to keep it PG,
the way that he looks at me.
I remember like when I first started hanging out with them and when I would talk
to them,
to my friends,
I would just be like,
oh my God,
his heart,
like his heart.
It's those eyes that just have so much life in them and so much love and so much
beauty and so sultry and so sexy and playful at the same time.
No Way.
I have sultry eyes.
She's,
she's mentioned my heart a few times and how she feels it,
but I think that's what she likes about me.
She said,
yes,
she did.
Not only do I find few,
just so beautiful in every single,
but you're infinitely compassionate with me when I have,
whatever moments I have,
we'll make whatever projections I make,
I'll go through my own stuff.
But beneath it all,
that's just how I feel with you.
Hey,
this really,
really appreciate you.
You helped me realize a level of self love that is so much deeper than I've ever
experienced.
Yeah.
Um,
I know you're going through some challenges sometimes and still be so hard on
herself.
I really feel like you're the whole package.
Thank you for
making me be more who I am and who I can be and for loving me all the way.
Yes.
This one is like,
I think we're in,
we've rocked this relationship
and.